thank you for joining us America this is
the Dave Ramsey show William is with us
in Hartford Connecticut I William how
are you good Dave it's a real privilege
to talk to you I'm a new listener I'm
honored to have you sir how can I help
have a problem that's embarrassing
I have a gambling addiction I haven't
filed taxes in five years about five
years ago I had two hundred thousand and
gambling winnings and after that I
haven't filed anything and I know of
course it's of waited to I mean I have
to do something you know you know I was
wondering what your I think I see on
obviously the advertisements on TV I
know I need representation optimum and
companies like that and what is you just
wonder you you still have a career I'm
retired
okay and do you have any money you mean
my pension you have any money anything
I've got about almost ten thousand and
my savings account okay but you don't
have a nest egg other than your engine
no okay
and your I do you own a home yes
about 13,000 remaining on the mortgage
what is it worth thirty about three
hundred thousand and how much is your
pension income ninety five thousand a
year that's good okay are you married
no okay have you done something about
the gambling addiction itself have you
quit gambling so whatever we do is going
to be a temporary fix because that's
going to further cause problems agreed
yeah okay all right so what would I do
if I woke up in your shoes and that's
how I answer questions on this show and
you're a new listener so you probably
have even heard me say that because I
say it all the time and so here's what I
do know I've done financial coaching for
thirty years and so we have worked with
a lot of people that have a lot of
different kinds of addictions what kind
of gambling are you doing what slots
really that's what yeah yeah I'm just a
lot of machines I got you all right
you lonely
I yeah I've been single for quite a
while yeah are you 61 okay okay what I
do know from having work with people
that are addicted to anything gambling
is the second fastest growing addiction
in America today the fastest growing is
pornography and what I do know is is
that 100 percent of addicts as you have
discovered eventually have financial
problems because it just it the
addiction consumes every compartment
Department of your life including your
financials and that's fairly logical
would you agree yes absolutely
and you've experienced that obviously
yeah so I I can help you with the money
parts of it but it is as I told you it's
a temporary fix until you until you deal
with this because it's not really
bringing you joy and you mentioned you
know being embarrassed and I'm sorry and
I don't I hope you don't hear me talking
down to you I'm not I'm just walking
with you in this brother okay no I fully
expected to be reprimanded I should not
write I'm not reprimand I I you're
embarrassed already and you're you you
know you took a pretty courageous thing
to get on the phone with me here so I'm
not going to take advantage of that I
want to help you is what I want to do so
what I would tell you to do is let's
take some steps to deal with the
addiction side of it and so like you
know we're about the same age I'm 56 and
so if you were my buddy and we were
sitting down over a cup of coffee
talking about this this is what I would
tell him to do okay I'll get in touch
with the gamblers anonymous folks in
your area and I would find a good church
in the area and start developing a
personal relationship with a pastor of a
church they can walk with you and guide
you and you probably need to find a
one-on-one counselor as well to help dig
into the
and see what's really going on so that
you can get the other side of this
because it's not it's not your life is
not better because of it and that's why
you called me right yes and there's not
even anything sexy about slots I mean
other kinds of gambling at least there's
some kind of a thrill but slots are just
boring as crud you know there's not even
it's not even got the edge to it that
some of the other stuff has so you know
that tells me where you are in your
emotions with this and again I'm not a
coach I'm not a counselor in this area
I've just worked with a whole lot of
people that are right where you are over
the last three decades and I see the
pain in their eyes and slots usually
tells me that it's a different thing
you're probably being stimulated by the
the noise and the crowd around you as
much as the gambling that's why I asked
if you were lonely yeah I agree with and
yes I I certainly am lonely I asked I'm
not going out to eat not because you
want to go to the restroom but just
because you don't eat by yourself
right and and I should clarify the slots
that I play or the high dollar yeah then
that does activate that does activate
the adrenaline rush then of the fear of
loss which is what you do get a drink
addicted to so okay yeah yeah yeah so
anyway let's take the normal steps that
someone would take that was facing an
addiction and you know get some
spiritual people around you in your life
get some people that have got some
success dealing with this kind of thing
and that's gamblers anonymous GA and you
can find them immediately now here's the
problem you've got if you don't go deal
with the other part of it you're gonna
have real problems scary problems
because failure to pay your income taxes
is not a crime failure to file is a
criminal act and so you got a real
problem you need to go to them the
meaning the IRS with some professional
representation before they come to you
and these if you're getting a big payout
at a major casino they're reporting on
you
so the IRS knows you're there and they
know your winnings because it's reported
as you know you're having to fill out
the paperwork if you're not nickel dime
slots but they're not but the big stuff
they're there they're making you fill
out paperwork and so the IRS got a paper
trail on you and you don't want them to
come find you in this situation so jump
on Dave Ramsey comm and click on ELP for
endorsed local provider for taxes and
see who's doing our tax prep work in
your area and if they don't do tax work
of this type they will have a reference
for you that you can trust that's not
just some goob on cable TV okay okay all
right and and so what they can do is you
can you can take some shots at this and
fill out the paperwork even if you don't
have the money you can go back a certain
number of years and get the filings done
and you'll avoid the criminal
prosecution you'll have the financial
issue whatever it is but you'll avoid
the criminal prosecution if you go ahead
and take action on this so you've got to
take action on that and it's gonna come
up again you're gonna have a problem if
you don't take action on the other stuff
we talked about agreed yes agreed
so William I want you to get healing
okay brother thank you so much Dave I I
know I need it you know and you call me
back if I can help you I'll be happy to
walk with you we'll be praying for you
so thanks for calling in now get in
touch with some tax pro get them to walk
you in out of the cold is what they call
them in that world and get back on the
grid with the IRS and that'll keep the
criminal part away if you come to them
and do it right there won't be a
criminal issue but don't wait on them to
come find you dude do not do that
that'll be a big
mistake you'll regret this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]